hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again in today's
video we're gonna be talking about the
season 8 faction rewards what they come
with what's involved who won and all
that good stuff so let's get started
with today's video also real quick
excuse the gameplay I am currently
working on another video that should be
going up hopefully in a couple days or
within the next week so if it looks like
I'm really bad at this game like I don't
know how to parry or I'm really just
[ __ ] with the commander the whole
time and not actually playing don't
worry about it
it all makes sense when the videos
released so I do apologize for that just
try not to pay attention to that it's
shitty anyway I'll admit it so first up
all credit goes the TSC desk on on
reddit I will link the image down below
if you guys want to see the full thing
but I'll be showing it separately the
video and talking about my thoughts
about it so all credit to him definitely
go down there I'll vote it all that good
stuff
very appreciative of him to post it but
just a case you're unaware the samurai
did win I believe they won 3 of the
campaign's of the 5 the Vikings won 2
out of the other 5 and then the Knights
won 0 so we're in last place but I learn
next time nice I'll probably get him
next season hopefully but first is the
outline and the samurai are in gold
the Vikings have this in silver and the
Knights have this in bronze just because
of the tier list of what they have well
placement they are for the faction war
and this is the outline it has some wood
spikes with a few arrows and a shield on
top looks really nice definitely very
excited for all the samurai players that
do get to use this I would definitely
use this myself eliminate your thoughts
on this outline I think it looks really
cool next up should have been the image
of the emblem but sadly I could not find
an image of it and descon did not put it
in the reddit post so sadly we'll have
to skip that and go to the ornaments but
this time the ornaments are faction
based that being for the Wulin the
Knights the samurai and the Vikings so
very interesting there and the Vikings
is first up and it looks like there's
going to be a bear on the front with
blue and red gems throughout the piece
looks really cool I like that always for
all these ornaments that was have these
little intricate designs in the middle
that you really don't see too much but
they make the overall piece look really
cool next up is the wool Lin and I
believe these are fish or Dragons I'm
not really sure on the top of the thing
like I said I can't really tell but it's
on top of the organ that looks really
nice with the same blue and red gem
surrounding throughout the ornament so
once again a solid ornament next up is
the Knights and I'm pretty sure these
guys got the worst of all of them it's
basically an all silver ornament with
barely any gems of color although this
could be because of the person's armor
so
be wrong there so take that with a grain
of salt well other than that it's a very
simple circle staple to the forehead not
really much to say about this pretty sad
of the night storm they have a good one
this season and lastly is the samurai
they have fish on the sides caving in
with a big red gem in the middle looks
really nice with a lot of small details
surrounding it so Rhett not really much
to say about the same right I do like
this one if I to give my personal
opinion on what I which one I like the
most I definitely prefer the woolen one
the most with the samurai second the
Viking bear thing in third and the
Knights being last since it's just a
simple circle yeah just to reiterate
just in case you're unaware the samurai
did when the Vikings came in second and
the Knights came in third if you're
unaware of how the faction world works
the winning faction that being the
samurai get access to the outline we
showed in gold and instead of all the
other colors they also get all the
ornaments that were shown in this
footage throughout the entire cast of
characters so it doesn't matter if
they're a night person and it's not like
it's only going to be to this samurai
heroes it's going to be for all people
of all the characters within for honor
but as long as you're part of the
samurai faction you will get this reward
that's how the faction war works within
this game hey guys it's gonna be the end
of the day today hopefully you guys do
enjoy let me know your thoughts and the
ornaments do you think it's okay that
the samurai won maybe they got maybe you
think these were shitty or maybe you
think it's cool that these are ornaments
and you're jealous that the samurai want
stuff like that so let me know about all
that in the comments below also I'm
sorry that this is posted a little bit
late I completely forgot the faction war
ended today I thought it ended in a
couple days so I'm a little bit late on
the video this should be up tomorrow
morning or I believe Thursday of the dev
stream if there even is a dev stream so
be on the lookout for the video after
that it will either be arcade or the dev
stream or both we'll see how that goes
so cuz I do believe the devs are on
Christmas breaks we most likely won't be
getting a dead stream for the next
couple weeks but as always like the V if
you do enjoy subscribe before new I
covered the informational side of
foreigner that being balance changes
hero updates patch notes leaks updates
to the game stuff like that to keep
everyone up to date on what's happening
in the world before honor including the
faction war and stuff like that
so that sounds interesting you want to
be kept up to date be sure to describe
to the channel that guys my two most
recent videos will be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out what that
guy's hope ever-greater day thank you
for watching the video enjoy those
rewards whatever faction you're part of
and peace out
[Music]
you